Pixar Animation Studios is the most successful
computer animated movie studio on the planet.
A subsidiary of the Walt Disney Company, Pixar
has produced sixteen feature films to date
- pretty much all of which have been universally
acclaimed - and there are another five planned
over the course of the next three years.Pixar
can hardly put a foot wrong, and their movies
have won countless awards - including multiple
Oscars.
Their movies genuinely stand up to some of
the best non-animated offerings of all time,
but they are by no means flawless.
Like any other movies, they contain mistakes
- some of which are pretty damn hard to spot
- and that's what this video's going to be
about.Here are ten shocking Pixar movie mistakes
you definitely missed.
Inside Out
The brilliant and unique Inside Out is set
inside the mind of a young girl called Riley
Andersen, where five personified versions
of her emotions attempt to successfully navigate
her through life.
Right at the start of the movie, when Riley
has just been born - in a scene that was used
for one of the movie's many TV spots - her
mother can clearly be seen to be wearing glasses,
but when her mother becomes visible from Riley's
own point of view, she suddenly isnt wearing
any - and there's really no way she could
have removed them in the time between the
scenes.
Ratatouille
In Ratatouille, there is a scene in which
food critic Anton Ego makes a negative remark
about Chef August Gusteau, comparing him to
Chef Boyardee as an insult.
However, although Chef Boyardee as a brand
is known for its pre-made canned pasta, the
fact is that the real Chef Boyardee - whose
real name was Ettore Boiardi - was a top class,
world famous chef.
He was known for being the head chef at the
Plaza Hotel in New York City, and he even
catered for president Woodrow Wilson's wedding
in 1915.
To use a comparison to him as an insult really
makes no sense whatsoever.
The Good Dinosaur
The Good Dinosaur takes place on a fictional
Earth in which dinosaurs never became extinct,
so we can't pick out the usual dinosaur movie
mistakes, like how they shouldn't be co-existing
with humans or certain animals, but there
certainly are plenty of others.
One example is when Spot, the young caveboy,
finds four other humanlike creatures and approaches
them.
Arlo, the young Apatosaurus and the movie's
main character, is shown using his nose to
draw a circle around them in a close-up shot.
However, it is clearly shown in other shots
that he is standing much too far away from
them to be doing it.
Monsters, Inc.
In Monsters, Inc., when the main character
Sulley - voiced by John Goodman - runs into
the locker room to shove the toys from Boo's
room into a locker, it is clearly locker number
193 that he is seen putting them into and
slamming with both hands.
However, when the camera angle changes, the
locker his hands come away from is, bizarrely,
number 190, even though his hands absolutely
didn't move from one locker to another in
between the two shots.
Cars
Cars follows the adventures of a number of
anthropomorphic cars and vehicles - including
a stock car called Lightning McQueen, voiced
by the hilarious Owen Wilson.
After Lightning catches up with a truck he
thought was his buddy Mack, he turns left
at a junction from what is clearly an asphalt
road.
However, while the turn is actually taking
place, the shot seems to show the road as
being made from gravel or dirt.
Apparently, a miraculous transmutation occurred
within a split second of the camera angle
changing.
Brave
Set in the Highlands of Scotland in Great
Britain, Brave tells the story of a princess
named Merida - voiced by Kelly Macdonald - who
defies an age-old custom by expressing a desire
not to be betrothed.
In one particular scene in the movie, when
her family are eating dinner, there's a blatant
factual error occurring.
They're all munching down on potatoes, which
wouldn't have actually been possible.
The movie is set in or around the 11th century
- in medieval times - and potatoes simply
weren't introduced to Scotland, or anywhere
else in Great Britain for that matter, until
around 500 years later.
Up
There is a scene in Up in which the young
version of Carl Fredricksen breaks his arm
and an ambulance inevitably turns up to take
him to the hospital.
This was when Carl was 8 years of age, which
would have been in the 1930s.
Back then, ambulance sirens were mechanical,
but the siren that sounds in the movie is
a modern electrical siren, which wasn't actually
invented by Motorola employees Ronald H. Chapman
and Charles W. Stephens until 1965, around
thirty years after that scene would have taken
place.
Toy Story 3
In the opening sequence of Toy Story 3, we
see Mr. Potato Head in his "One-Eyed Bart"
persona - One-Eyed Bart being a nefarious
bandit character that Andy often portrays
Mr. Potato Head as.
Seconds later, Andy's mother walks into his
room with a video camera, and Andy even refers
to the character as "Bart" while making Woody
arrest him.
The problem is, when Andy shows Mr. Potato
Head to the camera, he clearly and miraculously
has two eyes.
Not only did the second eye appear out of
nowhere, it also makes no sense that Andy
would be calling him by the name of a character
who's only supposed to have one eye.
The Incredibles
In The Incredibles, there is a clipping from
a newspaper shown of an article that criticises
and condems superheroes.
Under the headline "Super Menace To Society",
there is a paragraph with a mistake that can
only be put down to someone who worked on
the movie mishearing their instructions.
The term "innocent bystanders" is actually
misprinted as "innocent by standards", which
really makes absolutely no sense whatsoever.
Finding Nemo
Finding Nemo - a wonderful movie in which
the titular clownfish goes missing - is explicitly
set just off the coast of Australia, which
means that one character in the movie really
shouldn't be in it.
That character is Nigel - a brown pelican
voiced by Geoffrey Rush.
The problem with Nigel is that brown pelicans
- Pelecanus occidentalis, to get all technical
on you - don't exist in Australia.
The only pelicans there are Australian pelicans,
otherwise known as Pelecanus conspicillatus.
Brown pelicans are only found in the Americas
and if, somehow, one of them found its way
to Australia - which is incredibly unlikely,
if not absolutely impossible - then it would
undoubtedly be caught and destroyed, thanks
to Australia's extremely strict quarantine
laws.
Thanks for watching our list of 10 shocking
Pixar movie mistakes you definitely missed.
Did you enjoy this video?
Ca you think of any other mistakes in Pixar
movies?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.